Well, we're here in Columbus.
Came
because we heard they had some dowel out
here.
We can't get any dowel.
Can't find
Yeah, we'd love to. We would love to.
He's running. He's a coward. He's a
total coward. Try Try setting up a
debate with him.
Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it.
WHAT? THE DUDE HAS BEEN RUNNING. GOD
LOGIC LITERALLY CHASES HE CHASES HIM
AROUND BOSTON.
WHEN WHEN DID HE GET
HE
WAS STUCK SHEIK UTHMAN WAS INSIDE GOING,
"WHAT'S A DEBATE? I DON'T KNOW WHAT A
debate is." That's what he said.
You heard it right here. THIS GUY'S
SAYING IT. THIS GUY'S saying it right
here. It's going to Sheik Uthman. Who
Who's your dream team? Sheik Uthman,
Muhammad Hijab Muhammad Hijab Sheik
Uthman, Muhammad Hijab, Ali Dawah Ali
Dawah Ali Dawah
Then we'll get THE
HEY, NOW NOW NOW do something fun. Do
something fun. Contact those
Hey. No, YOU CAN RESPOND.
YOU CAN CONTACT THOSE THREE. Contact
those three and say you want to set up a
series of debates here. Watch them make
excuses. Watch them make excuses. I
guarantee. I guarantee. I got you. This
is me walking up to the mosque that he
told me to come to to the debate. Watch
what happens.
They stopped me immediately.
So, and then they told me to get off the
property.
They knew it was me and they knew he
said
They knew he said it.
Let's do this one more time.
No camera.
So, he said he can't come in with his
group.
Just him.
No camera.
No debate. What's a debate? That's what
he said. He can come in and only ask one
question and he has to leave.
So if he told me to come debate
and I show up to debate but he doesn't
let me bring my camera, he doesn't let
me bring my camera man in to capture the
footage and the conversation, he doesn't
want a conversation. He says just one
question and that's it. You got to take
it and leave. Is that Is that him being
honest with what he said or is that him
being dishonest?
Be honest. I don't know. You don't Look
AT YOUR FACE.
HE KNOWS. HE KNOWS. I don't want to
talk, Chris bro.
LOOK AT YOUR FACE.
YOU KEEP PLAYING THIS VIDEO OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
WITHOUT CONTEXT. WITHOUT CONTEXT.
WITHOUT CON- I gave you the context.
So the situation is they said they're
going to set up a debate with Sheik
Uthman and we all know that's like
fantasy land. When has he ever actually
taken part in a formal debate ever? And
basically Avery caught on to all his
tricks and he's running around the world
from him.
But they still think he's willing to
debate. Sheik Uthman is not going to
debate any anyone ever. HERE WE ARE.
STILL AT THE DAWAH BOOTH IN COLUMBUS,
OHIO.
Brother can't get ANY DAWAH ANYWHERE.
IS THERE A MUSLIM ANYWHERE ON THE PLANET
WILLING TO DEFEND Muhammad and the
Quran? Not one. Nowhere. Ever. It's
always IT'S ALWAYS IT'S ALWAYS SOMEONE
ELSE will debate. Someone else. Someone
else.
Back in the days
there was no such thing as age of
marriage, okay? There was such thing as
a woman has puberty and she and she
didn't have school. There's no such
thing as college. It was just But can I
talk Can I Yeah, but you just said two
false things. No, let me talk. You just
said two false things.
>> let me let me fix the false things.
Okay, let me fix it. All right.
I don't debate. Like you're a
professional debater, so you're talking
to a regular person who doesn't know how
We we Everyone will take that into
account. Okay. Okay. Thank you.
Come Look look, he wants to debate with
The guy was here. No, you're going to
answer. But I'm acknowledging he is not
a professional [laughter] debater or
anything like this. Therefore That's
fine. No, look. I don't want to talk
about it. I I want to speak out of
knowledge. You brought it up. She was
really 9 years old? Who? Aisha? Yeah.
Yeah. All right, where does it say she's
9 years old? Yeah, where's the proof?
Sahih al-Bukhari 5133 Look, they're
taking
Look, look, look, look, listen, listen,
listen. Sahih al-Bukhari says she's
exactly 9 years old.
Bukhari said she was 6 when married, 9
when they consummated the marriage.
Where does it actually show me that?
No, no, no, no, no. Sahih al-Bukhari
5133 Let me finish. Let me finish. Let
me
This [__]
>> Sahih al-Bukhari 5133, 5134 from Aisha
We have over The Hadith is from the
Bukhari, it's not from Aisha. No,
listen, listen, listen.
Hadith is from uh Aisha, it's not
directly from the Prophet Muhammad's
tongue. Okay? So,
and plus there's different narrations
where she said she was 7 It's Aisha
saying how old she was.
Okay, bro.
Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on. Hey,
bro. Hey, respect the dude. No. I'm
sorry. Then show me one. Show me one.
Show me one that says she was 13, one
that says she was 16, one that says
anything else. We have over 200 saying
she was 9. We have over 200 Hadiths
saying she was 9. Yeah, he does. So, why
are you talking to him? Well, he's
bringing it up. I don't get I don't I
don't I DON'T GET THE IDEA WHERE YOU CAN
SAY something false, and if I respond to
it, then you go, "WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE NOT SCHOLARS." YOU
SAID there was no
uh no age of marriage back then. That's
false. Romans, 12 years old. Um early
early Christian, I mean, once you had
Christians, it was uh 12 years old.
Judaism, 12. Rebecca, doesn't say.
No, she wasn't. I will bow down and
recite the Shahada if you show me a
Bible verse that says she was 3. Well,
we I will bow down. I will bow down and
recite the Shahada. I'm here saying it
right here.
It's false. Dude, dude, dude, dude,
dude, seriously. So, here's Uthman's
video.
Live stream, waiting for God Logic to
debate, wearing that same thing.
>> Same day in the same month, wearing the
same How do I know it's the same month?
How do I know it's this? How do I know
it's that? LOOK, JANUARY 24TH.
JANUARY 24TH, SAME DAY. SAME DAY, GREAT.
SO, maybe you prove that. I agree. Now,
there is uh literally a thousand things
that could have happened or THAT YOU'RE
NOT SAYING [laughter] THAT IS NOT SAYING
THE FULL TRUTH. LIKE WHAT? WHAT? LIKE
WHAT? ANYTHING. You could have been in a
different mosque. HOW? IT'S THE SAME DAY
AT THE SAME MOSQUE. YOU'RE PRETENDING
YOU'RE WAITING. OH, LOOK, MUSLIMS, I'm
trying to get in.
NOW NOW NOW
MAYBE ALLAH JUST MADE IT SEEM LIKE
DO YOU EXPECT ME TO SAY RIGHT NOW Sheikh
Uthman lied
>> Yes. without hearing his side OF THE
STORY?
OH NOW NOW HE NEEDS HIS MIC HERE NOW.
>> BRO, I NEED TO HEAR BOTH SIDES.
HEY I got you.
OKAY.
I GOT YOU.
HOLD ON.
IT'S SHOWING I HEARD YOU.
IT'S SHOWING Sheikh Uthman's life, his
side of the story.
No, because I saw both sides. I got I
saw both sides. I don't even hear you.
Help me, bro.
Bro, your your
your theatrics ARE CUTE, BUT THEY'RE NOT
they're they're not working. How can I
reach you? That's from Uthman's life.
That's his evidence. I'll be the first
to say Uthman would lie and he'd be
sorry.
Hey hey
do you think when he calls Sheikh Uthman
later that Sheikh Uthman's going to tell
him the truth?
>> [laughter]
>> Or you could be lying. OR YOU COULD BE
LYING. OR HE COULD BE LYING. Why would I
care about your guys' side of the story?
You have a live stream that is his side?
I saw you talking in person. Now I want
to see him talk in person, so it's fair.
IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT WISDOM TO FIND ONE SIDE OF THE
STORY. SO YOU GUYS THINK I SHOULD JUST
ONLY listen to your side? Brother, you
have Uthman's side. Hey hey maybe that's
CGI and
AI stuff. Maybe maybe AI made up or he's
just capping. Or he's just lying. Or he
went to another mosque. Or he did this.
Or he There could be a billion No, that
you watched the short. Now you're going
to go Now we're going to This ain't
Uthman, guys. Now we're going to his Did
I say it's not Uthman?
Yeah, you said it might not be it. You
said it might not might not be it. You
said anything. It's a AI Uthman.
You got to do that? Yeah, so he said So
I'm there at the mosque, right? So he
said that he the brothers told you to
come in. So, I'm there at the mosque.
Yes, or they told YOU ONLINE OR
>> [screaming]
>> WHAT IS WHAT IS SO CRAZY ABOUT THAT,
BRO? I NEED to hear both sides of the
story. He could HAVE TOLD YOU ONLINE TO
COME in the mosque.
What are these theatrics, bro?
When your boy ran, man.
He ran. I didn't hear both sides.
So, I should just hear your side. I
should just believe you. You're the most
honest guy in the world. Oh, that's so
cute. I'm more I'm more honest than
Uthman. That's so cute. That's so I'm
more honest than Uthman. That's not
saying A LOT. ANYONE'S
ANYONE'S MORE HONEST THAN
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION RIGHT NOW. IF
WE WERE IN A JUDGE, like a courtroom
right now, would the judge, out of his
wisdom, would he hear both sides or just
one side? Answer. Yeah, he would hear
the both sides that we show. Both sides.
Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. The judge
will listen to Sheikh Uthman's lie.
HE'LL LISTEN TO SHEIKH Uthman's lie. I
got you. He will see He will He'll watch
Sheikh Uthman's lie. He'll watch my lie.
Corroborate the evidence based on both
sides.
>> to you in person. And he'll say, "You
know what? And he'll talk to both of you
in person. He'll talk to both of you in
person. He'll hit his HAMMER AND SAY,
"UTHMAN AND YOU IS A COWARD. NO, HE
WOULD BRING BOTH OF YOU IN AND HE WOULD
MAKE YOU THE I NOW JUDGE THEM FOR UTHMAN
RAN.
THIS was fun. This was fun.
>> meet you, too. It's not nice to meet you
ever. Aw, come on. Deep down they love
me, guys. Deep down they love me. Not
that's what it says, but they love me.
When you talk to the people that speak
with him because he is
I do.
So, his side of the story, you
conveniently left.
His side of the story, YOU CONVENIENTLY
LEFT. EXACTLY. THAT'S HOW EASY BOTH
SIDES OF THE STORY
WAIT.
WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WHAT'S THE WHERE WERE
WE THERE?
WERE WE THERE? WERE WE THERE? I DIDN'T
SAY YOU WERE THERE. HIS SIDE
HIS SIDE I SAID MAYBE.
BUT THEN BUT THEN WHEN I SAW THE TIME I
WANT YOU TO SAY WERE WE THERE. SO, WE
WERE THERE, RIGHT? YES, according to
them, yes. Yes, THAT'S THERE YOU GO.
EXACTLY. THAT'S WHY I SAID I NEED TO
HEAR BOTH SIDES OF THE STORY. YOU GOT
ME?
THAT IS WHY.
THAT IS WHY. THAT IS WHY. THEN NOW YOU
GOT TO DO YOUR HOMEWORK ON WHY WE LEFT.
YEAH. EXACTLY. [laughter]
That's why we need Sheikh Uthman here
and then he would tell us Wait, Avery,
to my recollection, he told you to show
up at 7:00. You guys show up.
>> Yep. They don't let you in. Uh-huh. And
>> And he conveniently leaves when he wants
to leave, yeah. And they say and then
eventually and then and then you say no.
That was cute. We he challenges us. So
they go check with Sheikh Uthman and he
says, "WHAT'S A DEBATE?" AND HE SAYS,
"No cameras. No cameras. You can only
you can only
Just ask him one question.
>> Just ask a question. Have to take it and
leave it and get out of there. Yeah. So
you say no, that's not what we agreed to
and you leave and then Sheikh and then
after you leave, Sheikh Uthman says,
"All right, I'm ready. WHERE'S HE AT?"
OH, HE LEFT. He ran. After he hears that
you left, then he thumps his chest and
this guy right here, this guy RIGHT HERE
SAYS, "YEAH, THAT'S THE POINT."
THIS IS WHAT DAWAH does to your brain,
guys. This is what Dawah does to your
brain.
>> Yep, these are the Friday prayers, man.
That's the masjid mind, man. The masjid
brain. Columbus, Ohio.
>> Columbus, Ohio. Can't get any Dawah.
Can't get any Dawah.
Can't get any Dawah here.
Can't get any Can't get any Dawah. All
friendly guys, but can't get any Dawah
here. Not scholars.
No Dawah here.
They just
They set up a Dawah booth. And if you
show up and you want to have a
discussion, then uh
They get to pick all the topics and if
you say, "Okay, we'll go back and forth.
You pick a topic, we'll pick a topic."
No, no, no, no, they get to pick all the
topics.
Won't defend the Quran. Won't respond to
the Islamic dilemma.
Going to be a bad year for Dawah, guys.
Bad year for Dawah cuz everywhere you
go, it's run, run, run, run, run. Won't
defend I mean, it's just just think
about this.
If Islam is the truth, what do you need
to do to show it? You defend Muhammad or
defend the Quran? You
show that the Quran is the word of God
or show that Allah is a true I mean that
that that Muhammad's a true prophet. Do
either one of those, you you win. You
win. They won't touch them. They won't
go near them.
And so
Don't know what to do, guys. Is there
anywhere in the world anywhere in the
world
where we can get some dawah? So, you
guys agree with him on that all that all
prophets are Messiahs in Islam? You guys
agree with him? I didn't hear him say
that. Did he say that? Did he say that?
I need to see both sides of the story.
Amazing theatrics, bro. That's a little
sus. I'm not You don't never That's a
little sus, bro. Are you kidding? Are
you And he didn't call HE DIDN'T CALL
FOOTNOTE
HE DIDN'T WRITE FAKE BLOOD ALL OVER
HE DIDN'T BRING IN A LITTLE PAPER. HE
DIDN'T commit adultery with his with his
double buddy's wife. Right. And he
didn't see any of that. I didn't get a
restraining order for getting beat Hey,
I definitely don't believe this guy. He
didn't say that. This guy What am I
lying about? What am I lying about? What
am I lying about? Bro, you lied about
everything. You lied about everything.
You lied about everything. Got a
restraining You lied about everything.
choking him
You lied about everything. You lied
about everything, okay?
But that's not me saying that. He said
he's an expert because
You're dealing with cowards. They can't
defend the Quran. They can't defend
Muhammad. They can't defend any of it.
They want to attack Christianity and
they only do dawah. They only do dawah.
If they're TALKING TO SOMEONE WHO HAS NO
clue what they're talking about.
SOMEBODY TALKED ABOUT THE ISLAMIC
DILEMMA CUZ YOUR BOY SAID HE WOULD. I
SAID WALLAHI I SAID WALLAHI I would. And
and you lied.
And you lied. Right here, BRO. AND HE
LIED. YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T EVEN HE SAID
WALLAHI I WILL AND GUESS WHAT? WAS THAT
THE TRUTH? You can't even WAS THAT THE
TRUTH? WAS THAT WAS THAT THE TRUTH?
WAS THAT THE TRUTH? IS THIS THE TRUTH?
THEN WHAT? THEN HE LIED.
>> [laughter]
>> I WATCHED THAT WHOLE
WHY ARE YOU SO DECEPTIVE? NO, DON'T
shake this guy's hand. Shake everyone
else's hand. When you go to shake him,
okay? You see this? All I do is hold my
hand out to these guys. Okay, I want to
talk I hope you guys don't run. You
don't disappear like y'all doing today.
But I've been here for 3 hours, bro.
Don't worry. We're We're good. Come on.
Come on. Hey, hey, hey, [laughter] I
dare
this guy.
COME ON.
LOOK AT THIS. THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
FRIENDS. LOOK AT THEM. THEY'RE MAD AT
ME.
THEY'RE MAD AT ME, RIGHT? ALSO ALSO YOU
AGREE WITH
THAT JESUS is Yahweh? Y'all bro You
agree?
>> Did you did you hear his his Yeah, that
that Jesus that Jesus is Yahweh. No, you
are so deceptive. You are so deceptive.
>> ME IF YOU AGREE. YOU ARE SO DECEPTIVE.
>> If if Orthodox MUSLIM TELL ME I WILL
ADMIT I lost in a sense. If you agree
that Jesus is Yahweh in a sense. I WILL
ADMIT THAT I LOST IN A SENSE. YOU ARE SO
DECEPTIVE. SO according to what what
Orthodox Muslim thinks the New Testament
teaches, he thinks the New Testament
teaches that Jesus is Yahweh in a lesser
sense, right? According to his
introductory statement, he proved his
introductory statement. So so did you
listen? So
do you agree with him that according to
the Bible Jesus is Yahweh in a lesser
sense?
The the New Testament? YES, BUT YES,
YES, YEAH I KNOW YOU'RE STALLING.
According to the New Testament according
to that paragraph that what you guys
were talking about? Thank you. And so
okay According to THE NEW TESTAMENT
ALL RIGHT, NOW WATCH THIS. NOW WATCH
THIS.
DID HE SAY THAT YAHWEH IS THE MOST HIGH
GOD IN THE NEW TESTAMENT? BRO, you got
No, he didn't. No, he didn't. No, he
didn't. He's the whole point of him
saying it was in a lesser sense. It was
in a lesser sense. Notice notice I'm the
only one who brings receipts here. I've
been bringing receipts all No, you ain't
brought no I literally was holding
>> You ain't brought no Bible the whole
time, bro. I was on the Bible the whole
time. You ain't brought
nothing, man.
You all came to debate Now, he just said
that
Orthodox Muslim Flippiano did not say
that Yahweh is the most high God. So
watch this.
Hold on. Before you SAY THAT HE STOPPED
THE VIDEO. HE [screaming] STOPPED THE
VIDEO. I WANT TO SAY THIS.
OH, JESUS IS YAHWEH. Yahweh is the most
high God. Do you agree that God overall
to be overall is to be the most high,
right?
You're the highest overall? To be God
overall means you're the most high,
right?
If you're overall, including Yahweh in
the list of things, yes. Okay, so he
says yes, that's the most high. All
right, now. He just He just takes one
thing of what I said and forgets
everything else.
EXCEPT THE FATHER. SO SO
>> EXCEPT THE FATHER. SO SO THIS MEANS
EXCEPT THE FATHER. SO THANK YOU. WELCOME
TO THE OH, EXCEPT THE FATHER.
>> WELCOME TO THE TRINITY. THANK YOU FOR
SAYING THAT. SO HE PROVES HIS
INTRODUCTORY STATEMENT. HEY, GOOD JOB,
ORTHODOX MUSLIM. GOOD JOB, BRO.
IF JESUS IS HIGHER THAN ALL other things
except the
>> Except the Father. LET ME FINISH the
question. And he's only talking about
the New Testament. If Jesus is
If Jesus is high over all things except
the Father, does that include creation?
Yes. Does that include the heavens?
Yes, he he he he he
>> So
So Does that include all the prophets
and Muhammad?
He's talking about the New Testament
>> so he doesn't say he believes in it. So
don't be deceptive. He's talking ABOUT
IT'S NOT EVEN OLD TESTAMENT.
NOT even Old Testament.
Only New Testament. So watch this. So
with you acknowledging that Jesus is
higher than all things except the
Father, you just admitted that Jesus is
higher No, I didn't. No, I didn't.
According to the New Testament,
according to his introductory statement.
Don't say I believe Jesus is higher than
all things. According to the New
Testament Well, this guy's actually
trying to get a word in. I'm done, bro.
No, no, don't run away. He's actually
trying I'm not shaking ON THAT. WHY
WOULD WHY WOULD I RUN about Orthodox
Muslim? What is this book? Because Just
like you ran You you you YOU TALKED
ABOUT
HE WASN'T TALKING ABOUT ORTHODOX HE
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE BIBLE. HE
GOT VICTOR ON THE ROPES.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. THEY BROUGHT up the
Quran, we responded, then they said
we're running. And just want to talk
about the Bible.
They bring up Orthodox Muslim, we
respond, and then they say we just want
to talk about that because we're
running." Every topic they bring up, we
respond, and then they say, "We're
running from some other [laughter]
topic." It's like
That was insane, man.
See, that's what I'm talking about. So,
once you see that your boy has agreed
that the New Testament teaches Jesus is
the most high in some sense. Now, NOW
NOW WE CAN'T LET Now it's not
Now it's not allowed for us to talk. Now
it's not allowed FOR US TO GIVE
IT'S HARAM.
SO,
>> [laughter]
>> This is the best This IS THE BEST
DIALOGUE WE'RE GETTING ALL DAY.
THIS IS THE BEST DIALOGUE WE are getting
all day long.
That's the highlight of our day, ladies
and gentlemen, AS FAR AS
RUNNING.
RUN AWAY.
All the doggies ran away, bravely ran
away, away.
All right. Well, we're taking off from
Columbus State in Ohio. We heard
this is a place of dawa instruction.
So, we showed up, see if we could get
some lessons. Uh see if we could get
some dawa. What did you think of the
dawa the dawa scene here, man? It was
nonexistent.
I didn't I didn't get any dawa. I didn't
get introduced to Islam not once.
>> [laughter]
>> But I was hoping to get introduced. What
about you, Al? Did you get introduced to
Islam? I don't know. I had a Hadith
scholar show up for me, and they didn't
want to talk to me the entire time. So,
I had some good conversations with
others, but
>> a little crazy. Yeah. Uh so, we you
know, we we we decided to have a
conversation with them, and we we agreed
to do, you know, topic for topic. And
so, you know, just being the gentle
woman and gentlemen that we are, we
allowed them to have the topic first.
So, obviously, what What do you think
they guess to talk about? The deity of
Christ, of course. So, we talked about
the deity of Christ for about an hour
about him not knowing the hour and yada
yada yada. I bring in a counter-argument
on that topic. Once we finish that
discussion,
it's then he's like, "Okay, now let's
talk about the Trinity."
Like, wait, hold on a second. It's my
turn to pick a topic. So, I want to
let's talk about the Islamic dilemma.
Well, no, I will destroy YOU GUYS RIGHT
NOW ON the Islamic dilemma. I will beat
>> Trust me, bro. Just try like I could do
it right now. Why don't I do it? No,
it's my turn. This is a fair You already
brought your argument. You already
brought your topic. Like, no, dude. We
got a ar- we we brought a
counter-argument
to your topic, but that wasn't a topic
in and of itself. Now, we're picking a
topic cuz that old topic is over. Nope,
nope, and then it just became that he
ran from bring it from talking about an
Islamic topic. Like we knew that they
would. So, no Dawah.
Yeah, so, um it was this weird thing
where uh
he brought up a point and Avery
pointed out that he's being inconsistent
and showed him uh passage in the Quran
that exposes his inconsistency. And then
when it came for the next topic, he
said, "No, you already had your topic."
Which was So.
The idea was if we then debate the
Trinity,
obviously at some point Avery's going to
bring up the Quran or something. HE
WOULD SAY, "OH, YEAH, THAT was your
point that you got to brought up. So,
now we'll do it by next point and uh
it was just an obvious attempt to
control the entire situation. They were
terrified of defending Muhammad or the
Quran or anything like that. And uh
basically, Dawah, Yeah. the if you're a
Christian if you're a Christian who
knows about Christianity and Islam,
they'll only engage if they're attacking
the deity of Christ and the Trinity.
Other than that, they don't want to they
don't want to touch anything about it.
>> touch Islam. But what's amazing is if it
had been random students who know
nothing about Christianity, know nothing
about Islam, suddenly there would have
been all of this evidence for Muhammad
and the Quran, the scientific miracles,
the perfect preservation. They would
have had all this evidence. God logic
shows up not a peep, not a peep. And so
Dawa hunters continues guys.
>> Dawa hunting continues on to our next
destination. What is it? Ohio State?
Ohio State. Ohio State, here we come.
Let's see if we can get some dawa.
So we got Avery back here.
He is at
the dawa booth. Found a dawa booth here
at uh
Ohio State University. So
Cool times, cool times. Check it out.
Hey, what's up?
No, I was just going to look good. Oh,
oh. Hey Avery, what's your name? What's
your name?
Yo, what's up guys? My name is Saleem.
My last name is Wood, you know that?
What's up? My last name is Wood. Really?
We got the same last name. We're
brothers. Might be might be long distant
cousins.
My name is Muhammad. I hope not. I
certainly hope not.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey, what's up? What are you guys doing?
Man, I'm just chilling for real like we
just out here like
Hey, you see God logic? You know God
logic? You know God logic over there?
No, I didn't even
You know God logic? Yeah.
That's cool.
No, we were over uh Do I look good in
this camera though? You look really
good, man. And you're super tall. Are
you taller I think you're taller than
me, right? You the hugest though. You in
my way. Wait, where's this going?
I'm not lying. I was just recording a
little video a little clip of God logic
in the background.
>> What's God logic though?
Yo, yo, I feel like dates are under it.
They are. They're super healthy. I don't
know about if you cover them in
chocolate and stuff. That's that's a
different story.
Hey, he disrespected my last name. Huh?
He disrespected my last name. Hey, shout
out Mr. Wood. This is the real wood
right here. He disrespected my last
name. Anyways, anyways. You know, Jesus
did not eat pork. You know what I'm
saying? Like, hopefully it's beef.
True. He said he said Jesus ate
pepperoni. He said he said Jesus ate
pepperoni. Hello, pepperoni.
>> a Jew, so no, he wouldn't.
No pork. No pork, guys, just like Jews.
Woah, woah, woah, hang on. They Hey, if
they think Absolutely. But if you think
that's an issue I'm just asking. I was
just asking.
I was just asking. He We're chill. We're
chill, right? We're chill.
He wouldn't Jesus wouldn't have eaten
He's going to He's going to twist twist
the story, though. No, Jesus wouldn't
have eaten camel because that was
forbidden in the exact same passage that
eating pork is for forbidden. Yeah,
because washing your hands at the time
were not Jewish.
Right. So, what did you say? You're
saying that the dietary restrictions
changed from covenant to covenant.
>> Okay, that's that's fine. All I said is
I don't eat pork like No, how does it
taste, though? Like, what's it like? Is
it like good? Like Okay, if you think
like beef pork and like and like pork
You say beef pork? Sorry, pepperoni,
beef pepperoni and like No, wait, is it
the same, though? Am I missing out like
Yeah, are we missing out? Is it like a
It's like I've never ate a actual pig.
>> I think I think you're missing out, but
if you believe it's wrong, don't do it.
Don't do it. If you believe it's wrong
I'm just Does it actually taste good
like pork? It's pretty It's like the
meat. Is that Is that the butt of the
pig?
I mean, you can eat the butt of a pig,
but you know, you can eat all different
parts of a Huh? Yo, I'm looking kind of
good in this camera, though. I know. I
know.
Who you got, though? LeBron or MJ? Oh,
LeBron. Oh, yeah, that's actually a good
question. Ooh.
Yo, I'm going to This is going to change
my views. I can't First of all, can I
can I go back I grew up with MJ, man.
Can I go back to
You didn't know what it WAS LIKE.
>> [laughter]
>> YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS LIKE. YOU
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS LIKE. Maybe
you're right. Maybe you're right. Just
to be clear.
One on one.
In their prime.
In their prime. I TAKE KYRIE. LEBRON. I
DON'T KNOW. OKAY, NO, I agree with you,
but I think peak is different than who
is the all-time best, right? Cuz it's
also you're also You can't. He has more
longevity, right? Yeah, I think I think
He was MJ's peak is higher than
LeBron's. Okay, the real question is
like who's like packing more, like
LeBron or
Come on. Dude, come on. That's a valid
question.
No, no.
Yo, can we I'll point out that's how I
started studying Islam is just I had
Muslim friends. And they were converting
me to Islam and they But I have a I have
a habit if someone's like
uh here's this awesome argument. I'm
like tell me tell me the sources. I'm
going to go look them up cuz I don't I'm
not just going to trust you.
Ooh, that's a good question.
Good scholar, huh?
Like if you had to rank them Wait, if
you had to rank Islamic scholars
like just based off like I don't know
just like yourself.
Could you Could you give like a
shout-out to like the top three?
What Muslim like commentators? No, no,
like I like more of like
I guess still contemporary. I don't
know, just like your favorite Islamic
scholar.
Yeah, is there like Is there like some
you just want to shout out like Wait,
again, are you talking about like now or
like No, that's that's back then, back
then. E- either. I don't know, I tend to
I tend to stick with like the primary
sources like Quran and Hadith and so on.
Uh but I
go [laughter] like I go like Ibn Ibn
Kathir and
Wait, who else? Who else?
Any more shout-outs? Jalalain a little
bit that for just for some introductory
stuff. He don't go into detail.
Qurtubi, I don't know why I love Qurtubi
cuz he'll like give
He'll give
He'll give He'll give what everyone
He'll give what everyone [laughter]
said. He'll give what everyone said on
an issue. So, anyway, with that with
that whole situation it was
okay, if you're going in the direction
of going after people's wives and you're
saying we're not we're not on the level
of discussion anymore. If you're going
that route and you're going to go after
people's wives, I would just eat your
book. So, you tell me when you're ready
to stop.
What do you think about What do you
Diddy though?
I don't know the details but I know he
got found not guilty on some stuff but
if like 1/10 of stuff is true that's
pretty good Diddy.
What religion was Diddy? I don't even
know.
>> I don't know.
That's what it sounds like. It sounds
like some of it sounds like demonic some
of it just sounds like you're you're a
pervert who will get all kinds of money
and now you can do whatever you want and
you're just going to get worse and worse
and some of it sounds like satanic
rituals and stuff. I don't know but I
don't know. Are you are you friends with
Epstein?
Why would I be friends with with
Epstein? You kind of look like him
lucky. Stop.
You can kind of see it right? Say that.
You said all white people look alike. He
just said it.
>> I never said that. He just said it. He
I just want to I just want to not laugh.
No no no. No I see. What what's that? No
he just want to not to laugh.
Oh you can smile at yourself.
Smile bro it's okay to smile man.
What about smiling? You can smile at
yourself. Oh I smile all the time. Check
this out.
You don't want to be debating no one
man. You just chilling huh? Who? You
just letting God God does do the work.
They don't they don't want the smoke.
Yeah dick. I walked over there and said
they don't want any recording we don't
want to have an argument stuff like
that. I was like well I'm I'm going to
step back and Oh who told you oh this is
you can't record? Yeah the guy said he
said he didn't want to be
on camera at first. Then he did. It's
good that you're respectful people's
privacy. I am. Yeah. That's great.
That's uh That's amazing. I don't
consent
David prefers to just make a YouTube
video at home. What if I don't consent
to being on this? I'll turn I'll turn it
off. I consent though. I came here from
Why ARE YOU [laughter] LAUGHING?
WHY ARE YOU LAUGHING AT THAT? THAT WAS I
HAVE a blue passport he I don't even
know what color his
That's what I WAS SAYING.
HEY CHECK IT OUT. OH YOU REALLY YOU CAME
HERE trying to get some clips huh?
Yo shout out my boy Donnie. Hey Donnie
is coming in hey man.
Yo what's up?
You can lucky to be him though.
So, you guys all You guys all Muslims
here?
Yo, what are your thoughts on Trump
saying all praise be to Allah?
What are your What are your thoughts on
it?
Hey, this is actually kind of cool, man.
I'm right beside the
Ask a Muslim.
We got L and Avery over there.
We got these guys being super cool. Yo.
We always We're always always I used to
pray for times like this to shine like
this, so I had to grind like this to
shine like that. No matter what time I
spent on some luck that and then I light
it up. No, like Yo, what are your
thoughts on
What are your thoughts on Islam being
like the fastest growing religion? Or do
you think that's a myth cuz of birth
rate?
Um it well, the the the Pew research
study that said Islam is the fastest
growing religion said it was because of
birth rate. Hey, what's up, God Logic?
But isn't it What's up, man? But by
conversion, do you not think Islam is
the fastest growing religion by
conversion? It's not by conversion. I
think it is.
Um
like in the United States
I remember people converting to Islam.
I I agree with you. I Yeah, I know. I
agree with that stat. That That was Pew
research center poll. But I'm saying
like it's still the fastest growing in
terms of more the the religion most
people convert to is still Islam. I
never asked you
>> you guys come in and bombard this table
right here? What's that? What made you
guys come in and like bombard the table
right here? We were over at uh Columbus
State. Yeah. Yeah, so we were over there
and then [clears throat]
someone said there might be
there might be a dawah booth over like
on the field or something like that. So,
we went over and checked it out. There
was nothing there. And then as we were
leaving as we were leaving some people
some people recognized God Logic and
said, "Hey, they got a dawah booth set
up in the in the What's up, man? What's
up, y'all?
I'm on my way to
Hey. MJ LeBron. They keep bringing up
Muhammad Ali, man. Come on. You I'm
bringing up your name. Oh, hell no. Why
why you calling me for help, man?
Why you calling me for help, man?
Why you asking for help?
Why you guys called him over here? I was
saying, "What's [laughter] up?" How do
you call him over here and I'm I'm
asking for help?
Liviano, I'm with
This guy, what do you want to say to
him, man? I don't got nothing to say.
You got nothing to say?
I really think you need to talk you guys
need to talk, man.
These guys are losing their on our
campus, man. We can't let this happen.
You have anything to say?
You see this? You see this?
The Christian the Christians took over
the Ohio State. Nah, they did it,
Liviano. Everyone's becoming Muslim.
Hey, we good, Liviano. We good.
This is This is my boy right here. No.
Yo, what do you think about Palestine?
Yo, what are you waiting for?
Yo. Does Does
Do the Jews have a right to occupy that
land?
Which part? Palestine? Which part? The
whole thing? The whole thing? Yeah,
yeah, they definitely have a right to be
where they are.
What about Gaza? Yo, what do you think
about Gaza?
I wish there were peace and I wish no
one wanted to hurt each other on either
side.
I wish they had that that moral from the
beginning.
So, not the Zionist then. Are you a
Zionist yourself?
I know it's It depends on
There's what's called like Christian
Zionism that's like an end times thing.
No, I don't. Um
in a in a limited sense of
Jews having a place where
they're not under the control of other
people. So, that'd be that'd be the
sense in which I'm a like a Zionist.
Yo, I went to the community college. I
wanted to talk to like the the more
uneducated people. What are you talking?
No. You wanted to talk like the lower
class. You think college undereducated?
College, you went to Columbus State. You
went because you guys were there.
No, we went because he was there.
We went because he was there. Yo, this
is Yaqub. He said we got the the Wood
brothers in town. Uh you would just say
his name and and say something to him.
He's a he's a he's a good guy.
Hey, what's up? We got uh We got these
>> to say his name. His name is Yaqub.
Yaqub? Yeah.
Hey Yaqub, what's up? It's got the wood
boys here. Got my cousin. Yep. We might
be long-distance cousins. Yep, we are.
Aren't you black?
>> Wood represent. I'm a little black,
yeah. I am, too. Oh, really? A little
very little bit. Oh, like
Some some some one some one of my
grandmas down the line did something cuz
that came up in the DNA test, man. It
came up in the DNA test.
If I was knowledgeable enough, you know,
I would debate you on the religion of
Islam, but I'm not knowledgeable enough,
you feel me?
Not everything Not everything is
debatable, you know?
It was interesting. He was complaining
about the Quran thing, too, and I said
he's like he you need to you need to
respect people's religious symbols or
something like that, and I said, "Well,
what did you do if Muhammad after he
conquered Mecca went around smashing all
the idols?" Went around just smashing
idols with a stick and stabbing them and
stuff. He's like,
"That's not respectful." And then he's
like, "Well, what did Abraham do?"
Abraham was I'm not the one saying
you got to respect all this stuff.
So, anyway, yeah, I'm I'm still confused
on that. I don't know why it's okay for
Muhammad to conquer Mecca and have all
the polytheists there and then say, "I
can smash those idols." Guess what? I
don't care. I don't believe in those
idols. But if you're going to say you
need to be respect other people's
religious beliefs and stuff like that,
what's what's precious to them, then
then that's Y'all used to be the people
of the book for Y'all ain't the people
of the book no more. Like that's idols.
That's crazy. What about idols? Y'all
Y'all used to be the people of the book.
What are you talking I'm talking about
the polytheists in Mecca, man.
Polytheists. Yeah, but like you got to
think about it. Like the polytheists
weren't the people of the book.
We didn't want to respect them because
they're worshipping like polytheists.
You got to got to destroy that, bro.
Come on. I don't know if we can join
that discussion right here. You would
destroy idols. That seems That seems
>> they're about to get mad. That seems
that would get hectic over there. Except
Yeah. Yes, sir.
Like you're in a school That's They're
in an organization, right? They're in an
organization here. You don't want You
don't want them to get like in trouble
like causing a big scene. Like at the At
the the day we we leave. It doesn't
matter. It doesn't Nothing hurts us. But
that could that could come from us.
These guys are nice, right? Like most of
the dollar guys don't just come guns
blazing. These guys are super friendly
and then they'll just toss a little jab
out here. Honestly, I disagree with
their approach. It's a playful jab, you
know?
We're just here for a good time, not a
long time, you know?
>> That's good, yeah. This feel like this
is more like civil. Like we're just
sitting here having a good time.
Yo, yo, let's test his These guys over
there Let's test his hips. Let's test
his hips.
Oh, yeah.
No, it was uh we did some debates at
like the end of my junior year and I was
hanging out with Muslims afterwards and
I said, "You know what? I like this."
But I also like war. So it's weird. It's
like I'm happy with the
>> [laughter]
>> happy with the arguing, but I'm also
happy like chilling and Yo.
It's all good. What's going How's it
going? Good, good.
Yo, please clip that. Did someone go
tell him whose hand he's just shook?
Yo, yo, can we make a deal? Hm? Like if
you become Muslim, you give me 10 bands.
If I become Christian, Who's the Who's
the
That's an easy deal, like
10,000 dollars. Oh. If I become
Christian, I'll give you 10,000 dollars.
If you become Muslim, you give me Deal.
It's like a spoken Deal. Happens. All
right, so like one day if you become
Muslim, I'm going to take the 10,000.
You owe him 10K. That was just an easy
deal. You guys You guys have a take on
it?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, look at
this. Cuz I have a video of him I have a
video of him in high school. He said
he's going to marry her.
Anyways,
Okay, the deal is if he becomes Muslim,
he owes him 10K. And if he becomes
Christian, he owes him 10K. Easy Easy 10
for 10. 10 for 10, 10 big ones. 10 big
ones in my life.
That was after I was an atheist.
Really? Yeah. Oh. So I was an atheist,
went to prison,
got out of prison, went to school,
became a Christian in jail,
then flipped, man.
Atheist,
went to jail, became a Christian in jail
after about a year, and I to prison, and
I out of prison and left school. Do you
to philosophy overlaps with any of your
personal values? What's that? Does
philosophy overlap with any of your
values, do you don't think?
Oh, yes. Discussions a lot. I mean,
there's a
Philosophy is super cool because it's an
area where like lots of people try to
control what you can think and say, and
like lots of professors don't get mad if
you don't agree with their perspective
on things. Philosophers are like
usually pretty wide open on what
position as long as you can defend it
well. Like, they don't care if you're
arguing the opposite position from them
as long as you're arguing well. So, you
can have like an atheist professor and
write a paper on an argument for the
existence of God or something like that.
Generally, they're totally They're more
concerned with how whether you are
arguing well.
Makes sense. So, no. I loved it.
Did you ever like think of going back
like be a future professor or any of
that or Oh, couldn't.
You said what? I couldn't. That's why
That's why I ended up doing full-time
YouTube, yeah. Oh.
>> Used to be Used to be Muslims calling up
the schools saying, "Do you know that
this Islamophobe is Is at your school?"
Huh. And there's one guy saying Dude, he
used to stand out
>> They're probably right. He used to stand
outside the He used to stand outside the
school and be talking to telling kids
about me as they're walking to school.
This guy This guy
And this This is before any crazies.
This is before any eating the Quran or
anything. This is just like when I just
criticized Islam.
And I mean, back then, I was like I was
the guy who was like, "Hey, don't call
Muhammad a pedophile. It's not adding
anything to your argument. You want to
criticize it from a moral perspective.
You criticize it from a Don't be Don't
be
Adding Adding the insult is not adding
anything to your argument." Stuff like
that. I used to be that guy. Uh but even
that was too much. And so, I realized
I can't do both. I can't like have
public debates on Islam and so on like
that like I do
and be a philosophy professor cuz
they're just going to like harass the
university until they get rid of me. And
so, And so, it was like I either have to
completely back off of Islam or have to
just give up on being a professor. Cuz
like I'll become Muslim, but you know.
Yeah, become a Muslim. That would work,
too.
Did you ever see yourself becoming a
Muslim or is that like impossible?
Something like that.
All right.
I mean, it's always possible someone
comes up with some slam dunk argument
that I've never encountered, but
Have you ever talked like actual people
from knowledge or just like online
debaters like
Um
Have you had like a closed door debate
without like a million cameras there?
I mean, that's that's how I started. I
mean
You had that I mean, the first guy I
ever started having discussions with was
an Imam, right? We're weightlifting
partners.
So, we'd argue we'd argue about stuff.
We'd argue we'd argue stuff while
lifting weights and stuff like that.
Yeah. And then
and then I became best friends with a
Muslim in college and but he was like he
was he was really smart and seriously
good debater.
Um
So, that that went on for years and he
became he eventually became a Christian.
Hm. After he became a Christian, I
thought cool, I'm done with Islam cuz I
wasn't interested. I was way more I was
I was more interested in like the
objections of like atheists and so on
than than dealing with Islam. So, your
Muslim friend became Christian.
Yeah. And so, I thought he I thought I'm
done with Islam. It was about a month
later he got his first death threat and
it was attached to his car and I'm just
sitting here thinking
like this guy's life is now in danger
Right.
because he ultimately agreed with me.
Yeah. This kind of this this is partly
on me and he can't be facing this stuff
alone. So, I started
From that from that moment in my mind it
was like
here's an ideology that calls for the
public execution of my best friend.
What kind of person would I not would I
be if I didn't like stand up against
this? Well, the perspective of one
person doesn't necessarily like
encompass the perspective of everybody
else.
Like You know what I mean? What's that?
I said like the ideology of like a
couple people doesn't encompass what
everybody else has to think, you know
what I mean?
So, it's kind of all ideology.
Um
Of course, I know you know what What
thinks about going from Muslim to
Christian. Mhm.
But
But there's always like there's always a
couple of bad apples in a group of good
apples anyway.
Well, that's not bad apples and good
apples. That's
That's what Muhammad said. So
It doesn't mean It doesn't mean Muslims
are following that. And and by the way,
most Muslims would say that applies in
an like an Islamic state. Yeah, it
doesn't apply here. It's a Yeah, it
wouldn't apply here. It wouldn't apply
here. Um but still it's like okay, you
guys are spreading Islam. You're
spreading an ideology.
The guys who comes for my death and the
death of all my friends cuz like almost
all my friends are either ex-Muslims or
they criticize Islam in some way or
something that that they they'd be in
trouble for something or other.
And so it's always confusing me like
you're bad if you respond to something
that calls for the deaths of you and all
your friends. That This is weird to me.
Who How How did you become acquainted
with Christianity? Are you like
acquainted with Christianity or
How did your friend become acquainted
with Christianity? My Muslim friend?
>> Yeah. Well, he tried He He started
telling me to believe in Islam and
that's after I
left atheism and became a Christian.
Okay. And uh
and he started preaching Islam to me and
every wh- whatever argument he would
give, I would say "Where Where Where are
the sources on that?" And I'd go by the
sources and I'd start reading the
sources and then we'd start discussing.
And what made you choose Christianity
over Islam in the beginning? Like were
you
Like were you looking into everything or
just Christianity?
I I'd studied a just like
basic level um
Judaism, Christianity, Islam and
Buddhism. That was a long long time ago.
But Christianity was It was I was in
jail and I was arguing with a Christian.
And he ticked me off so much that I went
and started studying that. Wow.
I haven't seen the Quran yet, so that's
why I can't be mad at you. Once I see
the video, I'm sure I won't like you at
all, but it's okay.
For now, uh
we can be buddies.
Or aka they call you I said that. And
then you got a Christian who will say no
I'm so sorry.
>> All right, man. Listen, I didn't know we
was going to get the type of action that
we did. We went from
Columbus State
went over to Ohio State and some of the
Muslims who refused to talk to us about
the Islamic dilemma followed us to the
other campus.
They followed us. They called and were
like, "Hey, man, David Logic and David
Wood they're all here, you know."
Followed us to the other campus. They
sent They were sending pictures to each
other, letting them know that we're
talking and all that kind of stuff. And
so
the action was wild. It was amazing. And
what we saw was
when it comes to Dawah tables,
you ain't going to get no Dawah.
Ain't no Dawah going to be had. Ain't no
Dawah going to going to get be given.
Ain't no Dawah going to be exchanging.
All right? So,
it's tough. You a Muslim man? No, that
that was weird. So, yeah, cuz we were
almost we were about to leave. We were
about to leave. So, we were at Columbus
State
couldn't get any serious Dawah over
there
and they turned into a bunch of like
terrible crybabies who wouldn't, you
know, discuss any real
topic. And so someone said, "Hey, you
could go over to Ohio State. Check
things out over there." We walked
around. We're just like walking around
at random looking for looking for, you
know, Muslims, a Dawah booth, anything.
And then we're about to leave. We're
about to leave and some Christians come
up. They recognize Avery. They come up
to him and say, "Hey,
the Dawah booth in that student center."
And then we were like, "What?"
[laughter]
So, we walk over there. Avery walks
right up to the Dawah booth, starts
talking, recording, and then they call
security on us.
So, just to say that yeah, they're not
not not not what Like one guy said he
wanted no one recording and stuff.
And then so you were talking for This is
hours. This is hours. It's like three or
four hours talking. But uh it's
interesting cuz uh
you're
you've got the conversation there. L was
having her conversation. Other
Christians were having their
conversation. And then I was just over
on the side, but You
>> ended up talking to Muslims for hours.
>> they sat
Muslims sat down with David and went
live with him on
>> Went live on TikTok. And then they
titled it like destroying David Wood.
Yeah, but [laughter] they they're
laughing with him. They're talking about
who's the goat in the NBA, Michael
Jordan or LeBron. They love him. They're
asking like if I were a Muslim, what
kind of Muslim do I think is the correct
version and stuff. I'm sitting there
talking about all this stuff. But we're
talking for hours and it was uh it was
it it was silver gold. There's they have
they're chitchatting, but then they toss
in an insult and then and then we talk
for a while more and they toss in an
insult. And one of the guys came up to
me afterwards and he said uh they were
trying to rage bait you
to get to to to to tick you off and
stuff by attack by insulting you. And
one of the guys said to him in said to
them in Arabic, "Don't do that. It's
going to go after Muhammad. Don't do
that, right?" So they under they
actually understand the principle.
>> Um They understand.
>> But it was it was cool. I told him I was
like, "If they ever want to rage bait
me, don't insulting me is not going to
work. Like every time someone insults
me, I'm like, 'You don't know you don't
know 1/10 of it, man.'"
>> Yeah. And so so go after someone else.
Go after someone's family or something
like that. That'll that'll enrage
that'll enrage me. But uh anyway, ended
up talking to them and they're bringing
up lots of stuff. "Hey, what what's with
the Quran desecration? What's with this
and what's with that?" We talked for
hours. But some of them be like,
"Okay, I disagree, but I I kind of get
your point. I kind of get your point."
>> at a round table with David. They
surround David, but in a friendly way.
And I know but they they sitting the lit
like they listening to the big homie.
You know, they just they laughing over
there, joking, loving, and really
listening to his point of view. So
it it seems like a lot of them is they
say they hate you, but really they love
you. They really they want to talk to
you, pick your brain a bit.
Uh it's
really interesting.
>> It is weird. Deep down, deep down, none
of this makes sense. Muslims love me.
Yeah. Muslims love me.
>> None of this makes sense. Awesome times.
All right.
Now to Dearborn. Now to Dearborn.